generative AI apps or gen apps are
taking the World by storm we love our
chat Bots but what else can be a gen app
for your business
a fan favorite automated content
generation generative AI can facilitate
brainstorming perform copywriting and
generate media assets think emails
marketing messages and creative assets
searching and understanding large data
sets across many sources like when a
bank analyzes data sources to get a
comprehensive view of the market gen app
possibilities are everywhere product
Discovery and recommendation employee
recruiting and help desk customer Sales
and Service engagement technical
documentation creation and more with
Google Cloud's generative AI app builder
you get API access to Foundation models
that lower the barriers of building gen
apps sign up for Early Access
opportunities here